your first name Shawn has two ends I've  never seen that before what's going on I  have no idea I have no idea why you have  two ends in your name I mean there's  nothing special about it I think I asked  my mom but why did you do that I mean  because it was really annoying growing  up I'd go to baseball games and playing  tournaments and I'd go up to bat and you  know all excited to try to hit a home  run and the announcer to be like next  step Betsy and Scott my mom was like why  why did you add the extra n she's like  oh honey you know if you were a girl we  were gonna name you sunshine it's like  that surely doesn't answer my question  but I yeah I think there was some drugs  involved and they were probably hippies  right I think so yeah they were also  fans of Sean Connery right he said is  she's like but then we just added her  next to n yeah so that's the story it  doesn't sound like a ton of thought went  into it zero thought  you